come to Papa
hey everybody welcome to another edition
of come to Papa your favorite show of
all shows good to see you all hope
you're doing well here in the middle of
the winter
oh I'm faking my concern because it's 75
degrees here in California where I am
broadcasting today with my good friend
the very talented Bobby Lee oh thank you
so much you're welcome I will be
performing in Bellevue at the parlor
live up in Washington State
coming up Valentine's weekend woo lovers
and then February 20th I will be at
NJPAC in Newark New Jersey
back to the homeland and then I will be
it
laughs Boston up in Boston which would
be weird if it was laughs Boston in
Missouri but it's in Boston and I'll be
doing two shows there at the end of the
month go to Tom papa calm look up all of
my dates I will be touring like crazy I
hope if you're driving I think a lot of
people listen to this while they're
driving I hope you turn your GPS off
just for a minute
trust yourself you know where you're
going I was I trusted my GPS to come
here today and it just takes me horrible
places and then in the middle of it I
know I'm going to a horrible place I
know I shouldn't be listening to it but
I do because I've given up and I think
that the robots are smarter but Tom
Wilshire is the biggest street in
America it's like there's nothing longer
it's so long yeah either way you come in
you're just like I'm not even close the
wars in the Middle East is never end it
keeps going you are listening to Bobby
Lee's sultry silky voice you know Bobby
Lee he's a great comedian he's hilarious
you know I'm from his initial run on
MADtv and then since then nothing no
actually the opposite absolutely nothing
you could work constantly
I do work but just little jobs here and
there right that's what I like nothing
as big as the MADtv that was I've never
done anything really that big man taboos
big well you have 14 Mexicans watched it
so if that's big to you Tom then you
know it's big was that really the demo
yeah we would get the photos of the
people who are watching Raul was
watching and then we'd be like sign up
sign up but that was a pretty popular
show wasn't it my perception was that it
was popular well I mean it was um SNL's
[ __ ] how many years I was on it for
eight eight but the show was on for 14
holy cow yeah that's a big show I did
the last eight Wow
yeah but we never got any like
billboards or we never really were
advertised in any kind of magazine so it
felt like it's gonna be theater really
interesting yeah there was like homeless
people sleeping outside my dressing room
and stuff I was like no security did
shoot on Hollywood I Hollywood Center
studio oh my god I did a show there yeah
it's a nightmare it's all [ __ ]
prostitutes yeah outside outside yeah it
doesn't feel good doesn't feel like
you're on a show in the beginning in the
day you're like wow I'm I'm in Hollywood
and this is like where they did Lucy
yeah it's like a little crummy studio
but they had a lot of history a lot of
history and then the Sun Goes Down and
then all of a sudden you need some walk
out your car yeah yeah yeah very scary
see but that was that was a good for you
though I mean it well from doing just
stand up as an aunt open my Korea it was
a huge break for me I am that was early
how long were you doing stand-up when
you got that gig I had been doing
stand-up for about six years six years
yes I got really lucky I did on The
Tonight Show on Leno around the same
time and then I got mad TV
I remember getting out commercial too
was a really good year downhill from
there
that's a really sad after that but um
you know when you get stuff in the
beginning you get really excited and you
know you all these dreams in your head
I'm gonna buy this house yeah and just
that stuff just never really just as
miserable as you did you know when you
started and yeah we fixes you nothing
fixes you now yeah if you if you had if
you had a hit show right now would you
be fixed
I don't know cuz I've never been on one
but in my mind I think I would be fixed
but I don't think in reality I would be
because I'm still I still wake up with
me
with my face and with my you know for
like our defects I there's a love hatred
you know I mean as a kid I grew up in I
was born in San Diego but I lived in
Minnesota for a long time I had really
had no I really no friends oh no you
always look different I was the only
Asian guy in Minnesota yeah I think at
the time I was really yeah there was a
guy named Tom Roach who was adopted
uh-huh
but I don't really count that really you
know because like white parents and
stuff oh we did yeah but he was also
Korean uh-huh and my parents were my
father was very like an alcoholic and
your father was yeah an abusive he was
you know is physically my parents were
both physically abusive you know it was
a really dark kind of a childhood it was
he really just frustrated and with his
own life well no I mean he um he was a
boxer he was a professional boxer he was
in the Korean army and his record where
it was zero and eight like he never won
I lost eight in a row is he still alive
what is he still around they still
around yeah and um yeah he was an
alcoholic he was a workaholic also he
had this job where he opened a clothing
store called fashion gal and what it was
was like a lane Bryant before ethnic
women oh yeah yeah for like Samoans and
stuff you know Minnesota yeah in
Minnesota we had five of them and then
like I mean my whole family including my
uncles we had like 75 stores in the
country so yeah so then a little dough
yeah so they just my dad was just work
come home and get drunk and then go
crazy what would he get drunk um whiskey
yeah such a mean it's a mean one it's a
mean one yeah makes people mean yeah he
one night I'm sorry to be dark how many
kids my brother or not he brother yeah
one night I was about ten and my brother
was about seven and we 3:00 in the
morning my mom came into our room cuz we
slept in the same room and my mom's
mouth was bleeding and my dad had
punched it out no yeah holy cow happy
new year so he was
so he was he was kicking ass on
everybody yeah I mean he was extremely
crazy and then he's later when my
brother and I got bigger he wasn't able
to do it anymore cuz we fought back oh
really yeah you're like did you sit with
your brother and think look he's Owen 8
we can take him I mean the father is
such a dominant force yeah and you go
from like thinking he's a god and then
you know then slowly you like he always
there always on that mantle to some
degree yeah but to then have to like
consciously be like no I'm gonna have to
take him out if I'm gonna survive that
must have been a huge yeah and also
psyche that's where I developed my sense
of humor I guess you use it as a defense
mechanism right so it's a it's a
survival thing you know so I would act
up in school and um you know luckily I
didn't become violent myself you know
I'm a person yeah were you uh were you
funny in the house like were you trying
to keep it well yeah you like my brother
yeah my brother I mean he I think we
kept each other alive you know I mean my
dad chilled out later in life um I you
know I became a drug addict later like
in high school
I owned it three rehabs really did you
know that about me now I didn't know
yeah 14 see you're sober now right I had
12 years before so I've been in and out
of like sobriety so it all stems from
like I think my dad's alcoholism I
believe I was born with it
and yeah it reared its ugly head when I
was probably eighth grade eighth grade
yeah she hot
you know and stuff yeah and did they
were your parents aware of it no because
they're from a different country so they
don't you know when immigrants come here
especially in the 70s they don't think
that and they became in the 60s they
don't think that their kids are gonna
get into that right I mean my mom would
find um you know my pipe and weed and I
could just convince her that it's
oregano and it's for um cooking class I
told her that if she was okay she gave
it back you know and um I didn't
methamphetamines also no yes oh
yeah even know it was arranged yeah in
Poway where I'm from there was rampant
really yeah and she would find a mirror
and and their little straws and stuff
and she would give it back no yeah no
idea no idea but then it you know I was
on the wrestling team in high school and
I would cut weight with the math oh yeah
yeah and then I was too dark not at all
I didn't let my dark we've had darker oh
you have yeah yeah so I'll continue then
and yeah I used to cut weight with the
math and then but that spiraled into me
not going to school and then be acting
up at home and getting you know I mean
getting around home yeah so that was
high school you did get K yeah yeah
did you finish I got kicked out of my
sophomore year I went to rehab got sober
and then I relapsed and in my junior I
got kicked out again for a semester
right so then when I was in rehab the
third time was I went twice in my junior
year the third time I got it like I got
what happened was I was at this place
called the McDonald Center which is in
La Jolla mm-hmm and in one time in group
it was a lockdown facility so I had to
wear pajamas and stuff were you living
back out here he just came to the rehab
here no I was living in San Diego so we
lived in Minnesota that I moved out here
when I was in middle school so I didn't
get to yeah so I was living in San Diego
okay sits in La Jolla and I am one day
at group I let go Koreans aren't you
know mean alcoholics if you never go to
a meeting and see Asians you know mean
like it's a white people thing and a
black people thing sometimes Hispanic
but not never ours we're evolved you
know like we make things and we we have
good work ethic or whatever right and
the counselor was like you're wrong like
oh no you're not never seen it and then
he's our the next day I woke up and I
got a knock on my door and they go
there's a man in the lobby to see you
and so they brought me out to the lobby
and I want pajamas you know little kid
yeah and there was a man there a Korean
man with long hair down to his buttocks
and he had tattoos to his risk right he
looked like a character from Mortal
Kombat well and he looks at me right he
was adopted too his name was Dan uh-huh
and he was adopted later in life in like
when he was 14 or something
right right from Korea which is weird
he goes I'm done I'm your sponsor I
don't
I choose yeah but he's you're scary yeah
he is he's scaring me and he'll he
appointed himself and he changed my life
he did oh my god like he made me after I
got out of rehab go to a a meetings as a
junior in high school every day Wow made
me take a zero period so that I can
graduate with my class and a lunch
period and a seventh period that was
there like twice as long as any other
kid Wow yeah he really like I I went to
a monastery during the summer for a week
and didn't talk we meditated so I really
wanna trust him right away or know my
three resists my life
were you resisting him now I mean I knew
that I didn't want to die you were
conscious of that yeah I mean I was very
conscious of it and also I felt for the
first time in my life hope in my life
and so basically from eighth grade to
junior year is the time when you were
kind of spinning spinning really
spinning crazy and were you uh did you
feel that time that you were really
hurting oh yeah yeah I wanted to die you
did oh yeah I didn't want to live
anymore I had no reason to live I do
friends no not really you know yeah I
just uh
it was predominately like a rich white
kind of area I mean so it's like I just
didn't really felt like I fit in and I
you know how like they have like sadie's
Hawkins where the girl asks the guy for
the dance I never went to that one of
the girls would ask me I lived a painful
that's hard yeah you know it's
interesting as you're talking you know
if I was in a pretty white suburban
place and I fit right in and but there
were a couple Asian kids who really
struggled they really had a hard time
and you know I thought that we got along
and stuff but they did feel like they
were on the outside and I only bring it
up because today it's so different all
my god it's so different like a kid now
there's first of all there's more
everybody yeah there's more Asians and
stuff but even if there wasn't even if
the ratio was still to the 100 it would
have been embraced and looked at it's
such a more inclusive
in such a short time the Internet I
think the internet helped yeah because
it connected the world
uh-huh and when I go to my shows now
when I you know do shows did people to
come out like I'll see like an Asian kid
with gold teeth
none three white girls with him they're
wearing miniskirts you know man and they
all are dating him and I'm in my head
going this is a miracle it's so long
yeah because there's nothing during my
time right yeah I think it's changed so
incredible yeah I think it's great it's
great it's amazing I mean cuz that it's
you know we're not old that's like
that's a short period of time for the
yeah change like that yeah yeah I mean
because you what you have to do is this
is that when you're a kid you have to
have role models yeah right so growing
up you know all I had was kung-fu guys
right
like gatita Bruce Lee or nothing really
right right so it's like you know and
I'm not a fighter I like I was always
kind of fat and weird looking but I mean
I mean I was on the wrestling team but I
still was like very you know mean Joey
Joey you know me and um but wait were
you I was 105 oh my god um I was 5-1 you
know writing yeah
[ __ ] are you good yeah yeah was all
right if I continue to in limbs when I
got sober I I stopped that yeah yeah oh
yeah you did something else with that
beat my sobriety is what got me into
stand-up really yeah because what
happened was it almost felt like you the
career I thought you were gonna say that
when you said Koreans don't go rehab
I've got almost sounded like a bit I
thought you're gonna say and that became
my first bit like everybody starts
laughing I said I'll say you don't say I
don't want to do I'm where your credits
okay yeah yeah but yeah I mean I was I
remember being 23 sober and I really had
no future I literally was going to a lot
of meetings I was um you know very
active in that part of my life but no
girls no money right no hope right
didn't go to call
what were you doing what were you doing
honey the coffee shops and restaurants
waiting tables and stuff were you funny
yeah I mean I've always been since I was
sober the first time I'm funny you know
I mean that um yeah I mean not you know
just goofing around you know I mean a
lot of fart jokes right right farting on
people in South America yeah and then I
was working at a place called
pannikin and I worked another place
called disc FA and disc FA closed and I
didn't know what to do for a job
it was literally right next to the lowly
a Comedy Store have you been down to low
oil no I've been little high but not to
the Comedy Store oh really
no oh I don't you oh yeah because you
you want to get paid I'm on that what do
you want no because they were like more
of like this Comedy Store here right I
mean they'll give you they would
probably give you I don't know
but more than the normal is it a good
club it's probably one of the best rooms
in America but really they just don't
pay right yeah it's not it's not like
you know you're playing Bellevue right
with Reuben right I love that room yeah
it's a good room but people pay hard
cash right right they pack it out right
and you get a percentage probably
instead yeah so that's a really good
deal right yeah and low that's how I do
it they don't do that in La Jolla they
don't no they give you I mean they were
paying me 70 fight over the show oh
really
yeah she's I can't do that Kim but it
must been a fun place to start great
place to store yeah I knocked on the
door they wanted a arm a Help Wanted
sign for a barback I opened it in the
door open during the day it was guy Fred
burns you
he was paraplegic even the manager there
his hey what do you want I go I need a
job and he goes all right what hey you
work next door I go yeah and he goes oh
well can you wash dishes I go yeah and I
wash dishes there and then one night
during open mic i watched the stage and
i saw young people go up right and they
were horrible just absolutely the worst
thing you've ever seen
yeah and in my head I'm like oh I could
try it right and I moved up pretty fast
really yeah but did you have at any
point when you were younger were you
thinking comedy at all yeah you were
yeah because when I got sober
when I was 17 I got sober I used to go
down to the Pacific Beach improv uh-huh
and Mike Hirano who still works for the
company today runs that manager down
there with Dave Becky okay right so this
is the late 80s right and I used to
skateboard down there and I knew Mike
and Mike used to sneak me into the rooms
now I didn't know why I wouldn't want I
wanted to watch the shows right then I
know now yeah that was interested I was
drawn to it but like he used to stick me
back there and I used to watch I bring
it up to Tom Rhodes cuz Tom Rhodes was
headlining then uh uh Tom Kenny right um
Bobcat gold with a psalm all right I saw
Regan a couple of times cheese it was a
really eye opening who my favorite at
the time I really liked Bobcat Goldwyn
yeah yeah because he wasn't what I saw
in the movies he he was actually a very
good stand-up right yeah very smart yeah
all the jokes were good he didn't do so
much of that character on stage yeah
it would come out but he was um and also
on top of it a very nice guy right you
know and I think that's I learned that
from Tom Rhodes and Bobcat and these
guys that when I was a kid I mean they
didn't talk to me but they met my hand
yeah and they weren't douchebags
you see a lot of douchebags Tom you do
yeah we don't name names but you know
that they're out there yeah and I just
don't know why they're like that
completely yeah there's just well I
think there's two camps I think that
there is there's the one camp that as
comedians anyone who else is a comedian
they get a free pass right away and you
just embrace them and bring them in and
with and until they prove themselves
wrong they're they're part of the club
and then there's others who they're
comedian and in no one else is gonna get
in everyone's a competitor and screw you
you know yeah it's what I really am
enjoying now he's going around to
different clubs and using different
people to open for me and hearing the
stories of people who are shitty yeah
you know like at the DC improv it's like
this big you know it's like the green
room is like the size of a closet yet
yeah and to be in that tiny room with
two opening acts an emcee in the middle
guy and to act like a an ass to those
people in that tiny space could you
imagine like that would take so much
comfortable and but I and I've heard a
couple stories recently of like oh yeah
I open for so-and-so and uh he didn't
even let me stay in here no he didn't
even talk to me once and um
like for me I bring my future and the
reason why I do that is because of the
fact that I want to help these young
guys out you know and I use a lot of
women yeah I've used you know Whitney
Cummings back before she made it right I
used Sarah Tiana and Jake at a Preta and
a bunch of girls there's a lot of guys
too and I um I'd like to give people a
shot but it's like yeah I don't even I
don't even treat them like they're
opening their friends yeah exactly
yeah I mean the biggest thing is having
someone eat lunch with yeah right
yeah and somebody um just Ross it's fun
yeah exactly
I know you don't want to roll the dice
and be in some club with a guy you don't
know and if he just is awkward and you
don't you know mash and then you're like
all right I guess I'm gonna sell my own
I've made some mistakes though yeah I
took this kid I'm not gonna name his
name but from the Comedy Store uh-huh
and he opened for me at Caroline's
uh-huh and one show he was featuring he
gets off the stage he looks me right in
the eyes guess what he says he says
follow that like I bought him a hotel
room you know me I got him a plane out
there is ridiculous never used him again
of course not
yeah I was in Houston once and some MC
who I didn't bring it was just a local
guy guys yo man I don't even know why
I'm hosting on my headliner oh it's the
worst any you want to go well then just
don't do the shows then yeah why are you
here why are you here because I don't
want your energy into my show you must
they must be asking you to headline
somewhere then
yeah they're probably waiting for you
right now right now yeah but they just
have this you know attitude there is a
rash of young comedians right now I just
have noticed in the last month of very
poor not funny comedians but with the
confidence of a 20 year they're walking
around up on stage they're not walk off
like they just killed yeah and there's
just nothing there but they're so
confident I think it literally is a
manifestation of being told this new
generation being told you're great and
you can do anything and forget anybody
that's gonna just try and stop you so
they just walk around like it's all so
bringer rooms yeah there's a phenomenon
in the last 10 years called bringer room
whereas if you're a new comic to do some
of these shows like in the main room at
the Comedy Store right where you know
Sammy Davis jr. performed right and like
Richard Pryor and George Carlin Yeah
right right and now the Communists the
main room has these bringer rooms were
if you you can perform if you bring 20
people right right so what that gives
them is a packed room right so here
these guys are their new yeah and they
get the performer from these packed
rooms in the main room right and they
think they're like you know I mean yeah
my level right because of the fact that
I play the main room to know I you know
I was asked by there's a club to play
there right and so they think that
they're I know funny I know a girl who
I'm not gonna name her name but she's
rising and she's on tinder uh-huh and
she when she matches with guys she tells
them come to my show which is a printer
room so she has 40 guys that she matched
with know they're sitting in the in the
fill room thinking that they're gonna go
on a date with her and thinking they're
the only one they're the only one but
they're all there just so that she can
get into the show dad is brilliant yeah
she's very booking the room
through tinder from tinder yeah that is
hilarious she's gonna go to hell for it
oh my god
that is ridiculous second that you that
did open mikes correct yes for how long
I'm not that long I moved up pretty
quickly they started hosting me really
quickly what art in New York in New York
and I started doing like stand-up New
York a lot and Carrie - was the manager
there the owner and you know do open
mics we had some bringer shows it wasn't
like that many people lives you bring a
couple friends and they sit in the
audience and I just got recognized
pretty quickly and then he started
asking me to host the regular shows
awesome and then I just did all of that
and and just kept going I didn't really
the open mics you know you get kind of
like you know you you start out you do
everything but then you quickly realize
some things help you and some things
hurt you yeah and there were some of
those open mics that were so dark and
awful it was like I'm just this isn't
helping me sad it also doesn't you have
no carrot there are no you need to see
you to mean what it could what could
happen to your life yeah and a lot of
these open mic all you see is doom right
show up and it's like it's like a
therapy session you sign up and you're
you mean 96th on the list I'm not even
kidding you some of these when you're up
at 3:00 in the morning
you know man in front of nobody have you
ever gone onto one of those open mic
shows was like in recent years just
because you were happen to be there and
there was like a do you ever do that I
went to the Laugh Factory and I just
kind of walked in and there was it was
open mic comes like you know barren like
10 comedians just sitting in the
audience and Jamie's like you want to go
on I was like yeah I'll go up just for
fun and you realize this is the hardest
thing you can possibly do angry
uncomfortable room no one's gonna laugh
you're just I was like home I've been
doing this a long time and this is scary
you don't even like I don't even know
how I even got funny base on there
because you need to be able to like hear
yeah right laughter yes
eet's but most of those open mics you
could be do the best joke in your
arsenal and you'll get nothing yeah but
used but you do like if you you start to
see who actually can do it and who can't
you see you can tell I feel like right
away a hundred a hundred percent I mean
you can tell the crazies yeah
and you can tell guys that you know what
this person they just personally they
ate it yeah you can tell even if they're
jokes aren't there yet yeah you can see
that the thoughts there or you know I
mean they're intuition and you can just
see how that's gonna be they've got
something yeah did you uh
so you started there and you started
going up they just start putting you up
from dishwashing into the open mics and
bring her shows and the manager goes eh
if you've doorman on Saturday nights
right you can host so I said ok this is
great this is literally what this is
what it is it's like you he could tell
you wash dishes take the money from the
people sit in the stool outside yeah and
you don't even think twice like should I
be doing you're just like okay I'm going
to do this that's the difference of the
people who make it and don't make it it
literally comes down to no I'm just you
don't even think twice doing this so I
can be a comedian yeah and like if you
look back like if if right now if you
were like wait I gotta go wash dishes
yeah stand outside like you but you know
what Tom it was paved before us yeah for
me it's like you know like you know
Jimmy Schubert Ryan he I know that he
and Mark Marin I know that they worked
the door at the Comedy Store in the late
80s right so you know David Letterman
did the cover book at The Comedy Store
right Sam Kinison was a doorman yeah so
it's paper too before you right now with
this YouTube and stuff kids are like
getting fans right away and they're
getting rushed into this at the
spotlight and for me I'm glad that I had
that school a hundred percent right
because I got to I remember working the
door when I moved to LA I worked the
door right and George Carlin would do
once a year a week there well right and
jor
one time asked my name mm-hmm the kid
what's your name I go my name is Bobby
Lee and for three years after that every
week he knew my name really he never
forgot it
amazing right and you as a kid you learn
the class you know I mean yes well
that's why you're a great comedian you
know and you went through the right
things and you haven't act and you
really work hard at it and you are this
new generation of confident people who
call themselves comedians they have no
act they have no jokes yeah and they
don't know the other comedians yeah they
literally don't know who came before
them like you say you knew Marc Maron
was ahead and all these other people so
and the respect and you learn from these
guys don't even know who comedians are
they just know that they could put a
funny video up but you but they won't
last
you don't think no no I I begin I can't
last I thought that Tom but the thing is
is this is that now like you know I'm
with a pretty big agency right they're
signing up right all these youtube stars
and rank right and I'm not gonna name
the name but like I remember my agent
calling me saying so-and-so who's a kid
right right it wants to come to your
show he's got 8 million followers on his
YouTube channel already right yeah and
he's gonna come to your show in Pasadena
to watch you perform
uh-huh I want you to convince him to
just stand up right and so he came right
uh-huh
he saw my show and he looked at me he
goes I'll never do that I will never do
that why because he goes it just looks
too much work it's and it's like it's
too scary and whatever right and he's
he'll be fine and that's fine but he
won't be a comedian
oh that we were saying ok that's what
I'm saying yeah yeah you know that's
true they can be popular they can make
millions of dollars I'm not saying that
but they're not going to be comedians
yeah
they're not gonna be able to walk into a
room anywhere in the world and go up for
an hour and destroy right it's never
gonna happen
never yeah because you need the work
ethic it's
hard thing to build I know it and act as
a huge thing I know your act is so funny
I you know I started going to the comedy
store and by the way you're listening to
come to pop on Sirius XM 99 on raw dog
I'm here with my good friend Bobby Lee
what is your Twitter like Twitter and my
Instagram is Bobby Lee live Bobby Lee
live Bobby Lee live calm and I also like
to plug one last thing my friend yes I'd
like to plug my podcast it's called
Tiger belly is it a Korean influenced
agent one and it's my girlfriend and I
talked about our relationship how this
has been a couple years now three years
now yeah yeah and we live together and
it's great I remember she was going to
meet your parents for the yeah it was
very nerve-wracking you know she's so
crafty and kalila yeah because we spend
a night at my parents house and you know
if you spend the night in an Asian
parents house hmm it smells like a fish
market
in Okinawa like it's like it stinks from
a cooking
yeah it's cooking and then when you open
up the refrigerator there's always
things you have to explain like a
gigantic orange you know me I look like
a liquid you're mean that thinking what
is that you know but kalila yummy is
half asian right and then so I sleep
that night would kalila in our bad
upstairs and then I wake up at like noon
she's been up at 9:00 as she went
downstairs to hang out with my parents
and all I heard was laughter really I'm
just laughing at jokes and watching TV
and she's teaching them how to you know
you don't do the things on the internet
and online and I said she's good after
yeah you need a girl that crafting
that's great yeah I knew then yeah that
this is it Wow yeah you need somebody
that's gonna be like that with my
parents because my merriday I don't like
her get over it there's no way I can do
it but at what's your relationship with
your parents now I mean you went through
this time when your dad was completely
off the rails I got sober yeah and what
happened was when I got sober in high
school I wanted to live um make amends
to them and by making amends to them
what I did was I stayed at home after
graduation
couple years I worked at the store for
free uh-huh you mean I helped with my
brother like taking him to wrestling
tournament stuff like that and that was
a boy's counselor at the McDonald Center
and I just kind of was there for them
and then when I started doing stand-up
they kind of disowned me a little bit
so wait but when you were doing that
when you're doing three but when you're
doing those couple of years of being
cool and taking care of them and all
that stuff was he still drinking and
still abuse was but the relationship had
because he had gone through so many
rehabs with me uh-huh he learned that I
have a disease right learned about his
own disease he did yeah and didn't own
his down at all no no no but you know he
wasn't violent
well what happened but there's a switch
right oh that's good yeah but he was
still you know in his disease yeah but
he wasn't abusive to you any longer no
you know right and um so then you start
comedy and he's like that that's when my
parents were like what are you doing you
know right and I I go wall I do Stan
didn't even really know what it was
right cuz immigrants they don't know
they don't know prior right they just
don't know what what it is no all right
and they just know it's not a real job
they don't think it's a real job right
no and they think I'm gonna be destitute
and broke the rest of my life right so
every month I would ask for money that
moved to LA you know yeah and it would
be a fight send it to me and they acted
it as if you know I was dead really
really to the family yeah they didn't
really she talked about what I was doing
I mean I was sober and they were happy
about that
but um but what happened was I booked
Leno right what years this mm mm-hmm
and I booked MADtv also that same year
well it was a really good year but I had
booked Leno and that's when when I did
let all my parents on and my dad called
me the next day and he he cried really
yeah he cried and he said
I'm so sorry I didn't support you like
he was really wasn't years you know he's
because he also realized they both did
my parents that this was real this is
something that I really worked hard on
yeah and I've stuck to it the only thing
in life I stuck to like I'm such a
degenerate when it is everything else in
life like I don't know how to pay pills
I don't know how to show up for anything
really but would stand up I don't know
why yeah but I did it every night for
free for many many many years
right it's a beautiful thing yeah
sometimes I did two three nights it goes
back to what I was saying about how you
just have to want it and there's no way
around it like you there's no decision
making like but there's if your family
your family even turns against you
you're like I'm still going because
because it that - is an addiction right
right when you do stand-up what you
realize this but for me it was the most
uncomfortable thing I've ever done
mm-hmm well you go up on stage and it's
scary at first yeah but eventually this
is what I say to young comics when you
first start off you have to push
yourself on stage right but eventually
what happens you get pulled on right
right you get like you can't wait to go
up yeah
right so that once you get to that level
or that point your life is over
it really is yeah it completely is I had
going into the holidays I I was like
alright well I've got about two weeks
and we're gonna travel in New York as a
family and it's gonna be about three
weeks of not doing spots we're just
gonna hang with the family and I wasn't
thinking about it it's not doing spots I
just thought it of of it as what we're
just gonna hang out we're gonna see
family we're gonna do the holidays we're
gonna make lasagna we're gonna have a
good time yeah and about two and a half
weeks in I'm like cranky I'm like short
with everybody I'm like I'm just not
myself yeah and a dawned I'm like it's
because I haven't been on stage I
literally cannot survive without it any
longer you're right your life is over
yeah and then one spot and I was like ah
there we are
yeah hey hello real weird thing so
bizarre bizarre and it's like a lot of
people go well um there were people that
do it I'm I feel like I don't know if
I'm funny or talented I just feel like I
was just obsessed about it you're also
very funny I know but is it I mean is it
more obsession or is it more a raw even
talent it's both I mean you can't
it's a you've found a place to put that
bizarre talent is what it is and you you
have this crazy funny talent and there
happens to be a place where you can make
a living doing it and then there's a
then then there's the physical mental
part where you know exactly who you are
there I was thinking about this this
morning like how often does your mood
change when you're not onstage like my
mood changes like to the minute I
literally can be like I feel really good
today and then two seconds later like
yeah and then a little irritated and
then feeling it
I mean it's life is a very it's a very
difficult fluid but you ain't been down
but you internalize it though right yeah
totally
yeah yeah but when you're on stage you
know exactly the parameters you know who
you are you are in that space yeah and
that is to have that control over
yourself and your feelings and your
mental being is a very unique thing of
course you it it's kind of like a drug
it's like I know when you do a drug you
know how you're gonna feel yeah right
yeah yeah I drink I know I'm gonna feel
this way yeah stand-up is pretty much as
reliable as that yeah right yeah it cuz
it's also I think I always felt
invisible kind of uh-huh in life right I
would walk into a bar or a party and I
used to feel invisible like transparent
now like I in my head yeah I mean I
would torment myself in my head yeah
they hate me mmm nobody cares about you
here you know right like I would when I
was 21 I was sober I would go to bars
with friends
and they would hit on girls and listen I
just wasn't able to do that yeah I just
look invisible uh-huh but as a stand-up
I know no longer felt that way yeah in
fact I was the guy getting the girls
yeah you know and it was it was such a
drug it changed every portion of my life
it's so great
I mean it's so funny to think of you
even in that way because like I was
starting to say before I started coming
back to the comedy store or really for
the first time going to the comedy store
on a regular basis here in LA and I
loved it it's just such a great club
it's it's the closest thing to New York
for me that I can get and it's so funny
because for a while I was always
following you
yeah every time I walked in you were on
stage and it's so funny to hear you talk
about you being like this shy guy
because you dominate the room you just
this the minute you can't stage but you
and you walk around with your belly out
and you just completely natural it's
like there's no way there's no reality
you could sit and we could do this
interview for three more hours and you
talk about how quiet and shy and hard
you're up now you're a beast just up
there like completely controlling 200
people yeah but you missed it Tom
you came in you're part of the reason
why the Comedy Store now is great uh-huh
because there was a tie with I've been
there as a doorman since the mid-90s
like I am but I have never hopped ship
I'm very loyal yeah I'm a loyal person
like I'm Korean in that way where I have
never left my net agent like the reason
why I'm with CAA people go you with CAA
Vegas but the only reason why I'm with
them is because I followed my agent from
the smaller agencies up up right I would
just we won't leave each other right I'm
the same way with the clubs right so
I've been at the Comedy Store since the
the medieval days when we on a Tuesday
night we would have no audience really
and we had to wait for two hours for six
people to come
Shh yeah it was a dismal start yeah but
but when like a couple of years ago
right it shifted yeah and we got a new
talent cratering right and as soon as
that happened it just shifted and you
were one of the pleasant surprises that
name
it was sober yeah a lot of New York guys
dove Davidoff a lot of these guys right
showed up and we got rid of all the guys
that would just made that place so on
fall there was like a a weird like slew
of people that were just negative it
just felt like a crate it was a negative
ways yeah I would do four hours on stage
Oh No Oh like I mean I could name him
because I don't really like the guy Eric
like Eddie Griffin oh really
Eddie Griffin with a I'm going up right
and I'm four or five hours and then we
wouldn't people go on literally four
hours every night no sometimes it would
go Eddie Griffin Andrew Dice Clay
although I'm friends with dice and they
would do three hours apiece three hours
yeah and then Mencia would be there to
go up after dice oh my god it was uh it
was the worst club you could ever
imagine and then we get no audience uh
because that you would just see that and
then if midsi when Mitzi was cooking in
the room yeah she there was like I'm not
even kidding you Tom one time on the
lineup
I read Roderigo no one had a tie that
was going on uh-huh
it was Mitzi's landscaper who told her
that I would do something things for
free around your house no I've always
want to try stand-up oh my that's what
we would be oh my god but as soon I mean
god bless me to see I mean I I do love
her for making me a regular yeah if you
don't know who Mitzi shore is like it's
Pauly Shores mom yeah and she started
the comedy store back in the early 70s
her and Sammy Shore and um she started
everyone's career yeah and she's a
legend Letterman they know where the end
of her you know mean of her reign there
yeah she kind of lost her mind it's kind
of like your grandma who can't cook
anymore
I mean that's what it was
yeah and you know and so you were very
pleasant surprise man oh it's so great
and it was it's so fun to watch you work
in there it's you're so like free I
think you're so I always feel like I'm
always like what should I wear I don't
know like what should I wear
and you just roll up there your t-shirt
half on do you think about what you're
gonna wear at all you're just like no
you know why because here the thing is
this is that people said honey in the
beginning of my you know as an open mic
or they say well you you know I think
stand-up should be classy and should
wear a suit or whatever people would say
well and I just felt like you know you
know just be myself
you ain't and even in my material like
it's pretty crazy some of the things I
say I just don't really change the way I
do it because it's like it's me I mean I
apologize that that's me but I refuse to
do it any other way we ya know that's
why it's great it's like you know I I
just you know I sometimes wake up and
I'll just go you know I'll wait I woke
up at yesterday at 6 p.m. hi what did
you do nothing I played video games so
what time till like 9:00 10:00 in the
morning till 9:00 10:00 in the morning
yeah
wait a minute so you the night before
that you were on stage probably yeah you
got home at like midnight or so home I
say hi to my girlfriend I'll make a
sandwich uh-huh midnight yeah midnight
2:00 in the morning I'll go you know
what I'm gonna play some fallout all
right and then 9:00 in the morning I'll
go to sleep from one o'clock til 9:00
you're playing oh my god I mean
sometimes I play with Eric Griffin who's
on work a call workaholic yeah
human Oh we'll get online together and
we'll play till 10:00 at night 11:00 in
the morning
no yeah and I and I will not stop really
no I play that great I play about nine
ten hours a day holy cow
yeah were you like how long you bunch of
different games you've done that way no
I'll stay with him for a year I play
with destiny right and now fallout came
out so now I'm playing what's fallout
it's an art role-playing game you create
a character
right and it's a post-apocalyptic world
okay it's time it's in Boston uh-huh and
you just kind of walk around and you
have a dog or you can have a girlfriend
in in the game yeah you walk around and
you build houses okay and you shoot
creatures and it's a really fun game
it's gotta be fun yeah Xbox
they both Xbox and Playstation right and
I can't believe my girlfriend still with
me
here what does she do when she gets up
to go to work in the morning what you
this is what you do with any
relationship if we're listening and it's
new I don't hide things up front right
you see up front okay Brett this is my
life okay I play I do whatever I want
yeah okay I play nine ten hours of video
games a day I I nine or 10 hours a day
yeah it's such a long time yeah it's a
very long time I do stand-up so at
nights I go on the road a lot right and
if you can't deal with it then this is
not gonna work out right you know yeah
I'm weird man I'm weird sexually you are
yeah I weird fetishes and weird things
that I do what's your main fetish well
I'm just I could well I don't know if
your audience members would care but I
like I'm a choker uh-huh you like to
choke or beecher I like to be choked to
be Chuck yeah I'd like to get like a
little violence right yeah and my
girlfriend actually I didn't know this
about her uh-huh
but I met her on tinder yeah we went on
a date and then a month and I knew that
we were this was gonna be a thing uh-huh
but I waited a long time to have sex
with her right but the first time we
hooked to hooked up we were on a futon
on her couch
I mean futon in dinner plates in Long
Beach uh-huh and we're making out and
she punched me in the face
and then she said this afterwards she
goes tell me you want to kill me and as
soon as she said that I literally
started crying you knew you're like oh
this is love this is pure love and the
Lord did it yeah this is defining and
then she also said I don't care you play
video games I love that you do stand-up
right and all the things that I need
in my life mm-hmm she's able to be there
for that right
and she's also good at cuz I'm on the
show I'm reoccurring on a show called
love it's on Netflix uh-huh it's Judd
Apatow
Netflix show oh you know I play a
character in it yeah and like you know I
we went to the wrap party for the first
season and I here's the thing you need
to know that your date can handle it
right I'm gonna tell you the story I was
on MADtv right and I met a girl who was
an open mic arm stand up mm-hmm and I'm
not gonna name her name a here uh-huh
and she's doing me on yet no she quit
yeah but she was also leading me on she
just put me in a friend zone right away
but you intended like she wanted to hook
up with me but she didn't yeah so I
decided to fly her to the upfront uh-huh
which is if you're on a TV show I was on
MADtv right every year you go to the
think all the upfronts where they bring
out shows and you meet the critics and
the end that press too big it's a big to
juice thing yeah and so you know a Fox
we had American Idol you know Pamela
Anderson had her own show at the time
and so I bring this girl out right so
there's a dinner with all the shows and
you're in the center of the of this
dinner is the President and all the
executives right of the network yeah
thanks
so I'm at the MADtv table yeah we're
talking and I'm thinking where's this
girl and I look I see her handing out a
business card to the president of the
network No
and she says I'm a stand-up and you
should check my stuff out as if that's
the way you make it in this business
oh my god it up um I grabbed her arm
yeah
Island and I pulled away and I said
sorry to the whole table oh the only who
I was was like my fifth season yeah at
this show yeah so they all kind of
laughed him in right because they knew
what I had brought to the out front
right yeah and I said if you ever do
that again I I will kill you because you
know mean if it wasn't you know it was
easy
it was my first year on a show yeah and
that would put a real negative effect oh
my god yeah it makes you look
unprofessional
it makes you look crazy - yeah right of
course
so when you're now a stand-up or if
you're in showbiz in some way yeah you
have to pick a partner that can deal
with and know how to survive in these
situations right right you're not gonna
like if I piloted this love rap party
yeah and she gets tries to get a photo
with Judd Apatow no that's not gonna
happen right and kalila knows those
instincts Ryan that's good she doesn't
do those things that's great yeah I'm
sure your wife doesn't do those things
no no exactly yeah
but what does your wife do your
girlfriend do when she has a job like a
straight job no she what happened was
and now we're gonna get depressed again
and now we're sad again no no but she
she was a nurse yeah
and we went to the Philippines when we
first dated hmm and she had a heart
attack she did yeah she has a heart
problem Oh No yeah defect we had surgery
right and right now she can't work oh
man so that's why I decided to start a
business with her so we started this
podcast it's doing well that's and now
he just got you know a company to do our
merger stuff that that so um we're you
know making money how good but so that's
what she's doing but her heart it's not
great yeah and we're at the hospital a
lot yeah at 3:00 in the morning she will
go I'm having a an episode Shh and so we
we go to the hospital
oh my god yeah and um it's another
reason why I know cracking it's
nerve-racking so also a reason why I
know I truly truly love her because I
treat her like she's like my mom or dad
like she it's that the idol and Dean
yeah that urgent so I race over there
and it is it's an eye-opener yeah yeah
no that's real life stuff it's real life
stuff it's kind of that thing where you
you kind of break through when you
really love people and it's like you
don't think twice you know you just do
stuff you just do it you do you know
yeah exactly
yeah now how how upset you when she has
an episode in the middle of
video games that must be horrible
could you play fallout for like an hour
or it's just it's just gonna suck you in
like would I put fallout in my xbox well
you play for an hour you have an Xbox
yeah are you a gamer no well then no I
mean you yes I mean yes you could play I
could yeah but yeah because you're not I
wanna be like I have an Xbox yeah but
I've just got I have a I have so many
kids yeah I've got so many people I
don't know right yeah I have three cats
and cats they just do their own thing I
mean we're recording this at noon and
you said on your way him like I almost
didn't make it I couldn't I just so
early for me I barely woke up I was up
at 7:00 I've I've already worked on my
act I went for a run I dealt with my
wife stuff drove over like I mean my day
is winding down I don't even know what
that is what you're doing why when I
watch you at the comedy star like he
seems like he's just having so much fun
with it yeah right when I'm doing a spot
at 10 o'clock at night it's like whoo I
have been up a while but Tom you know
what I miss
what I'm missing in life yeah is having
children yeah you'd be a good dad yeah I
mean I miss my Ganic element of what I
think life is about uh-huh I'm selfish
in that way you got time you got plenty
of time the old though you're the gear
the guy what do you mean doesn't matter
it does does not because I look at Joey
Diaz and up yeah he just has a newborn
yeah and he's in his 50s yeah and you
know and he's older than you though yeah
yeah yeah that's true but not that much
older i but in essence he's older yeah
yeah maybe you're young
yeah you're young again I if I have a
kid I can't play 16 hours of video game
today
not until he's six and it's like well
yeah all my friends comic friends I'll
magical steamers is he uh-huh all these
people say you gotta have it yeah our
lives deep burn just had it has a second
one coming yeah and I feel like it's a
trick
it is a trick you're trying to trick me
so that then when I have one you're
gonna be like ahaha yeah yeah there'd be
a little part there's a little part to
all those guys it'll be like yes finally
he doesn't get to do whatever yeah yeah
there's nothing a look to not have them
it's not a bad way to go either you can
let me ask a really good lie you real
with me Tom for sure be real with me
okay what are the benefits the benefits
are is love you have these people it's
just it fills the house it's it's adds
to your life you start seeing the world
through not just your own selfish face
but through these other people's faces
and it's just a little bit more you're a
little more connected to the natural
world and the rhythms of time and life
it's a deep thing that's real it's real
but give me the negative your life is
not your own yeah that's the biggest
negative and look there's a certain
point where you kind of give in you're
like you know what am i doing anyway
yeah but you seem to really be enjoying
it yeah but let me see this so I have
three cats yeah I know they're it's not
the same thing
Wow one of my cats my middle one is sick
you know he has a little we don't know
what's wrong with them all right there's
something internal going on if he's
diabetic yeah so I go I go and I've been
taking him to vets waking up earlier huh
I really care I want him to get fixed
sure so I know that I would be a good
father I know that I have the intuition
yeah I mean to do it it's just that it's
the fear of not being able to that's
what you like you said I I want to be
able to do what I want to do but there's
sacrifice big time huge yeah I mean I
went through it to you look you're
you're similar we're similar in that
you're tight with your parents yeah
you're tight with your family's
important to you obviously yeah you
still went through all that with your
folks and stuff and you're still tight
means that family is a whole
a big place in your life so you know to
not continue it would be a sacrifice
you're sitting you know that you're
sacrificing either way you're gonna
either sacrifice your free time and all
this fun crazy Bobbili experience solo
or you're gonna sacrifice not having the
continuation of a family continuing all
that stuff yeah I have it I have this
vision mm-hmm that because sometimes
when I go on the road and they come back
you know like kalila will better sisters
or whatever else coming into a empty
house with cats yeah it had this vision
of a kid saying daddy right uh-huh
and I I get why that that would be an
appealing thing mm-hmm
to have a kid when I'm going to sleep
like obviously if I had kids I would
change my sleeping patterns you know and
like you know having kid next to me just
look at me you know in that way mm-hmm
would be thrilling I think and I think
it would change me for the better it's
just it's just that fear factor of
actually pulling the trigger because
it's said there's also financial things
too right yeah but that kind of takes
care of itself you work hard you know
how to deal with your stuff yeah you
know look my biggest thing honestly was
my wife and I we both were like I don't
know if we're gonna do it
the one I met her I kind of knew it was
gonna happen but I was like look I'm a
comedian you're an artist you soak up
everything in the world and you
experience life why are we not going to
do that
biggest one why are we gonna deny
ourselves the biggest experience and
that was the thing that clicked I was
like yeah why would I yeah not go down
that road oh my god so then I did it and
it's not you know it's hard and there's
a lot of there's a lot of years when
you're confused and you're fighting it
because you want to hang on to your life
and all but it's the experiences are so
rich and so non-stop good and bad it's
just you know what it is not having kids
is like living in LA it's like you do a
couple things see a couple people we
just kind of blitzed out in the Sun and
you just kind of yeah a lot happens to
you having a family is like waking up on
a cot in Times Square where just there's
just that much stuff happening
bombarding you all the time Wow yeah
you'd be great either way I'm gonna do
it you should probably do it I wanna do
it you should do it but promise me you
won't change no I mean I'm gonna I want
to see you if you have a kid I still
want to roll into the comedy store and
see you in a goofy sweatshirt sandals
but I think also impressions of your dad
my material would change and that's kind
of something that I'm also curious about
yeah also is that your funniest stuff to
me is when you talk about your dad yeah
and you talk about your place in the
world yeah to extend that is just going
to extend your act yeah I'm gonna do all
right great we maybe did something here
today all right you this was a great
time which plug some things Bob all
right so I'm on love which is I'm only
in three episodes and then I'm also on a
thing called the awesomes which is Seth
Meyers cartoon I've been on it for four
years oh cool and I never plug it and I
want to plug that yeah and Tiger belly
my podcast and that's great it's good
stuff well I mean I know I have some
road dates coming man yes please and I'm
gonna just say people be Tom Papa fans
III at the end of my shows III kind of
get naked at the end so if you know if
you don't want to see that then don't
come to my show but completely naked
sometimes but I mean the Houston Improv
February 12 through the 14th good and
I'm also at the Chicago improv February
18th through the 21st nice and then
that's it awesome I love you thanks for
having me on you're the best you're the
best I will be off in a Bellevue up in
Washington that's close to Seattle they
close the Seattle Club so this is
Seattle basically so I'll be there
February 12 the lemons literally one of
my favorite clubs by the way parlor live
amazing it really is a good one and then
the NJPAC a big theater show in New
Jersey go to Tom papa come find out all
the rest of the dates Bobby thank you
thank you for getting up in
and even time for you buddy alright
everybody see you next time enjoy your
life